Hey, everybody.
Welcome to another Rollback.
What is Rollback?
Well, Rollback is where we bring the best
of our pre-video catalog to YouTube for the very first time.
And no best of list would be complete
without this absolutely incredible three time podcast guest,
the ambassador of Sweat and Swagger herself, Robin Arzon.
Robin is a former corporate lawyer turned ultra runner,
New York Times bestselling author,
and massively popular Peloton instructor.
She is a female empowerment inspiration at large
for many reasons,
not the least of which is the fact that she walked out
on her secure corporate career to pursue her passion.
She also survived a hostage kidnapping incident,
uses that experience to fuel her direction and gratitude,
and she currently manages her extremely active lifestyle
while combating and very transparently sharing her journey
as somebody who suffers from type one diabetes.
Simply put Robin is a modern day warrior.
She is fueled by the ethos that there is no finish line.
Her life's mission is to redefine, reform,
and rethink possibility through movement.
And to remind us all that we have the power
to change the story we tell ourselves about ourselves.
Well, how did she do it?
It's time to find out.
Here is episode 99 from August 10th of 2014,
with the singular Robin Arzon.
All right, we're doing it.
(Robin laughs)
Let's proceed, accelerate.
What's happening, Robin?
Oh, I'm good.
Hot New York City.
I know.
I love it though.
You know what I like?
I like...
I like how it's really warm in the mornings and at night,
like you don't, you know, everyone thinks sunny California,
you know, especially in the summer,
but it gets chilly at night and I like to work out early
in the morning and I like being warm, you know.
I hate, I hate being cold,
so like getting up early and running
when it's like nice and warm out, that's like a treat.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
It's kind of like a misty moist blanket welcoming you
on a morning run.
Yeah, it's not a dry heat.
Definitely.
No, you know.
But last time I was in New York, it was February,
and it was in that massive snowstorm.
Oh yeah, and you're not a snow cat.
No.
I'm digging it, so I'm having a good time.
I get so juiced from the energy of the city,
and you're somebody who puts out a lot of that energy.
You know what I mean?
New York is my, is,
I say New York is my boyfriend.
Is it?
Yeah, I mean, you know,
it's like I have real relationships of course,
but for as long as I can remember,
New York has been a real player in my story, and, you know.
I can't imagine you living anywhere else.
I don't think it would work.
I know.
I mean, it's like I travel.
I was just recently in India with my sister and my mom,
and I mean, people will just stop
and take photos of my tattoos.
And I just don't think,
I mean, of course I dress conservatively
in the areas that required it,
but, you know, it was still very much a visual conversation
I was having with a lot of these folks.
So, that was interesting to-
Well, you definitely,
you've definitely found your niche
in merging your personal brand of fashion with fitness
in a very New York kind of way.
Thanks.
That's the goal.
Like, yeah, you have like a whole thing going on
with that.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, the rings don't come off
even when I'm doing trail races.
I know, yeah, like on your Instagram,
which is always inspiring by the way.
I love your messages and your Instagram.
So, if anybody is out there who just needs like a smile
for their day, follow her on Instagram,
and it will definitely help in that regard.
Awesome, thank you.
But I was wondering with all the bracelets,
like, if I'm like out doing stuff all the time,
like I would feel like I have to take them all off
or they start to get gnarly.
So I'm like, how does she wear all those bracelets
and be like sweating all the time?
I don't know.
Like, I mean, I got-
Well, I guess they're like rubber, most of them.
Yeah, well these.
And then I mean, I do have a pretty big cuff
that I'm actually not wearing now.
And I did like a 20 mile run the other day
and it was like giving me a rash,
and I'm like, all right, there are clearly limits
to this whole sweat with swagger thing.
But yeah, I mean, the rings don't come off.
Like, the rings are-
Rings are always on.
24/7.
Oh and you got the freaking gold plated fuel band.
The special one, right?
Yeah.
So yeah, it's actually dead right now, but,
yeah, I'm a fuel girl.
So, are you working with Nike right now?
What's the, like I'm trying to get a grip on like the whole,
how it all works in your life.
I mean, I've done a lot of different,
I've been working with Nike
in a lot of different capacities.
So, I've worked with them on the digital side.
I used to work
on a team running the Nike Women's social media.
I've worked as talent, as a fitness model.
I've worked as a running coach.
They've sent me to sort of host, you know, workouts
and stuff internationally,
but it's just, I'm a friend of the brand.
It's not like an official relationship.
It's just on a case by case basis.
Right.
They need to do like the whole Robin look,
you know, like the whole line.
Have you helped them do design?
I haven't helped them design anything,
but I did help them style their running looks
for the 2014 season.
That's cool.
I mean, it's a conversation
that have sort of been dropping those seeds,
but I would absolutely love,
love to come out with the Robin NYC like merchandise.
I mean, but something that is functional
but has the swagger.
So much fitness stuff, even now,
even as it's becoming more and more popular
and more lifestyle so to speak in terms of sweating
in a lot of different capacities,
it's still, it's not up to what I-
What it could be.
Yeah.
Not how you can really rock it.
Just do your own, do your own thing.
I know.
And it's funny because I was actually,
I had the designs and everything
for a leggings line I was gonna launch last year.
And I was using my own savings from law days,
and I was like, this is it.
I'm gonna press go.
And then I realized really quickly
that I was in no way, shape, or form willing
to sort of devote the time that it was gonna take
to literally getting it out.
I mean, I was like, okay, now I have these great designs.
Who's gonna send it out?
Me. Who's going to the post office?
Me.
So, then I had to like put a pause on that whole operation.
I'm like, you know what?
I'm a one woman show.
So, I need to partner with an existing brand
to make that happen.
I mean, if you thought you were working long hours
as a lawyer-
Oh yeah.
You know, forget it.
Like, Julie used to have a garment line,
and she tells stories about what that world was like.
And it just sounded like her life was completely insane.
And you can, the thing about that industry
from what I gather is you can, you know,
start a line and start small and do okay
and even get into like the cool stores
and even, you know, find a way to get celebrities
to wear your stuff and all that kind of thing.
But you can only grow it to a certain point.
And it's consuming your life
'cause you always have to be getting the new thing.
You know, constantly have to be coming up with new designs.
And if you want to kind of get over that hump
and get to like play with the big boys,
you need like a massive infusion of capital to do that.
Big time.
So, so many garment lines, they just don't make it.
Yeah and the small operations,
I mean, just to break even like, you know,
when I was pricing fabrics and I mean, I really,
it was like, I was about to press go
with my first 1,000 pieces.
And just the pricing when you go from 1,000 to like over 10,
over five or 10, like the big brands do,
it's night and day in terms of how much it costs to produce.
And of course I wanted to produce it ethically,
so I was using a local, like New York, Brooklyn designer.
And I was like-
It's gonna cost too much.
Oh, like an arm and a leg.
And then to price, yeah then to price it,
it was like, the wholesale price was astronomical.
The consumer thinks you're being greedy
and like making all this money, but like,
and then you send it out to the people that sew it
and manufacture it, you send out your patterns or whatever,
and it comes back.
It's like, here's a, you know, make this banana
and then it comes back an orange,
and you're like, what did you do? And they're like, what?
You know, like it's just a weird, you know,
the rules of how that business operates are super bizarre.
For sure.
It felt like a game of telephone at times.
And it really was just consuming so much
and taking away from other parts of things
that I really find nourishing.
Yeah, you wouldn't be doing a lot of urban running.
No.
So, you know what I mean?
It's sort of like,
how do you balance all these different things and be-
Yeah, no kidding.
Yeah, for sure, it's a battle.
So let's get in, I want to get into the backstory.
You know, your story's fascinating.
And just for the people that are listening out there,
Robin and I met at Catalyst Week in Las Vegas last year,
which was a really cool couple days that we got to spend.
And it's sort of a...
How would you describe it?
Like, a curated kind of monthly or bimonthly kind of event
that Amanda Slavin puts together
where she brings interesting people out
to downtown Las Vegas sponsored by Zappos
under the, you know, auspices of Tony Hsieh, the CEO there
who is trying to revitalize downtown Las Vegas,
and his project is called the Downtown Project.
And he's bought up with like,
I think he spent like 300 million of his own money
or something like that.
Something astronomical.
Bought up like six square blocks
of the downtown part, not the strip,
but the downtown part, which is kind of downtrodden.
And he's trying to revitalize it
by kind of investing in startups
and making it attractive for young people to come out there
and bringing inspiring people out to develop an interest
in what they're doing there, and it was really cool.
So, that's where we got to meet.
And I got to hear your story.
And so I want you to tell your story.
So, take us back to the beginning.
Oh, back in the day.
I'm gonna have to, I'm gonna have to like refrain
from like spitting out hip hop rhymes.
This mic is just too juicy.
I want the authentic Robin,
swagger, New York experience.
Oh Lord.
No, I mean, I grew up in Philly.
I, whatever, idyllic childhood, all that.
I ended up, I was not an athlete whatsoever.
I was, I wrote, I forged notes on my mom's medical pad
to get out of gym class.
And I think I always had this duality of like the kid
who was really good at school
but with this like very much rebellious streak.
And yeah, went to NYU, had plans of becoming a lawyer,
did that.
I went to law school and that's when I started running.
And-
Why'd you start running in law school
if you had never been an athlete?
Well, I think,
in retrospect I know the real reason,
but back then I thought it was just to alleviate stress,
like this quote, unquote "stress."
But when I was in college, I ended up getting held hostage,
like a crazy-
Right, like this is, I want to hear this story.
'Cause this is like a huge moment in your life.
I mean, it is.
It's probably one of the most transformative moments
in my life that's still,
you know, this happened 12 years ago,
and it's still, I still carry it with me.
I was just in a bar in the East Village with my friends
and this guy walks in with a gun
and happened to walk into the bar that I was in,
shot this man lying on the ground.
Well, oh, sorry, let me backtrack.
This guy walked in who had already been shot.
Then the man who shot him followed him in.
Then he shoots him a second time,
grabs me, I was just sitting on a stool by the doorway
drinking a glass of wine.
A few months before my 21st birthday, but whatever,
I think that's besides the point.
The statute of limitations.
Yeah, whatever.
And then he grabbed, he grabbed me by my hair,
and it was a really, really narrow, tiny wine bar.
And he's just, I mean, expletives flailing.
Like, he's, I mean, he's basically saying
that people are leaving in body bags.
And I really didn't,
in those moments, like time actually slows down,
and you're like, what is actually happening here?
I mean, your body's trying to process it,
and then it's in shock,
and then it's just these really base like,
base emotions of survival kick in.
And that's when he hands me garbage bag ties
or throws them at me
and he tells me to start tying people up.
So, I'm tying people up
with these like slide plastic garbage bag ties,
trying to make it loose enough,
so they can get out if they need to
but not so loose that he can tell that I'm doing that.
And then he lifts me, oh no.
Then he starts spraying us with this flammable liquid.
He's spraying us with kerosene.
And I had literally chunks of my hair ripped out
from how forcefully he yanked me.
So he, but he,
so he shot this guy outside of the bar.
The guy is injured and runs into the bar.
He follows him.
But the guy has like spray kerosene on his person?
Oh, he's got,
later I found out he had multiple guns,
he had swords, like full on samurai swords
underneath his clothing.
He had a catheter.
He had a catheter on him
'cause he planned for this takeover to take days.
So, I mean, that was like...
I mean, thankfully I didn't know any of that at the time.
I saw the gun, felt the gun,
and then he starts spraying us with this flammable liquid.
And then busts out a barbecue later
and starts flicking it in people's faces.
It was in that moment that I was like,
okay, this isn't a robbery.
This is like, he wants people to die.
Yeah, this is a psychopath, straight up.
Straight up.
And he grabs me,
and he proceeds to use me as his main hostage,
like as a human shield, essentially.
Body to body, I was right in front of him.
The NYPD are now outside of the bar.
It's a tiny bar, so this, I mean, this couldn't have been,
I mean, it wasn't that many feet,
maybe like few hundred feet away, if that,
and he wants to talk to the police outside.
So, then I became this like pseudo negotiator
where I'm calling 911 on my cell phone
and then negotiating between this guy, Steven Johnson,
and the NYPD outside.
And I'm asking for his demands.
He has none. And then he starts speaking to me in Spanish.
Somehow he was able to tell that I'm Hispanic.
I'm Puerto Rican and Cuban.
And then I'm like,
all right, maybe I can humanize the situation.
So, in Spanish, I start talking to this guy about his son,
about his family, about his life,
and trying to really figure out like what it is
that he was doing there and how to salvage this.
And, you know, he really didn't,
I mean, he was just so disturbed.
And the only intelligible parts of the conversation were
when he was talking about his kid.
And at the time his son was 10 years old,
and his wife had just died of AIDS.
And I just think he was an unhinged racist.
He wanted to kill white people.
He wanted all white people to die.
Very explicitly said that multiple times.
And...
It was, I just remember like the refrain in my mind,
I'm sure there are many things,
but what I remember so distinctly was thinking,
this is not my story.
And it was one of the first moments
that I understood my life as sort of the story
that I was putting out into the world.
I think before then, like, yeah, I dealt with stuff,
but pretty, pretty uneventful life I think until then.
And then at 20 when you're kind dealing
with your own mortality
and then the mortality of 20 other people
'cause you don't wanna set this guy off,
yeah, it is, I mean, I think major is an understate.
So how long did this go on for?
It was only like two hours.
But when you're going through that, it felt like a week.
And how did it, how did it get resolved?
So this woman, Ann Margaret,
who I didn't know at the time but now I know,
she was sitting in like a wash basin, like a sink.
She lunges up and jumps him from behind
at one point when he holstered the gun
'cause he had the gun to my right temple,
the barbecue lighter to my left,
and then he is dealing with like me and the cell phone.
So, he's juggling a lot.
Then he holsters the gun in his waistband,
and she just jumps him from behind.
And then all I felt was the sensation of falling.
And then I see the NYPD rush in.
I heard a gunshot.
Ended up just grazing his temple and he's fine.
He's alive.
They just bum rushed him and tackled him.
And it's amazing that that got resolved productively.
Nobody died.
Four people were shot and nobody died.
I mean, that is like, that's a success story.
And this woman, Ann Margaret,
I mean, she saved your life.
100%.
Like, a real life hero, yeah.
And do you, do you still, you talk to her still?
Do you know her?
Yeah!
I do know her.
She's doing so great.
You know, I was already in law school when, or no,
we became really friends after this event,
and then I went to law school,
and now since then she's become an attorney.
She has a kid.
Oh wow.
So like, you know, our paths are, it's amazing.
Like, she's an incredible person.
Now she's a new mom, so I'm happy for her.
And the perpetrator, he's in jail?
He's in jail.
He was indicted on 72 counts.
Wow.
So Rikers will be his home.
And did they figure out like what was motivating?
I mean, was there,
I mean, who was the guy who he initially shot?
Was that just random?
Totally random.
And I just found,
I just recently found out coincidentally,
I was speaking to one of the experts
that they had engaged on the case,
and she told me, 'cause I wasn't supposed to,
because I was a witness and I was involved,
I really wasn't supposed to know more
than my own recollection,
but, you know, 10 years later I happened to meet this woman
and she told me that he wanted to kill Jewish people,
and he was going to the Second Avenue Deli
but it was the Sabbath.
It was Saturday, Shabbat, so it was closed.
No one was there.
Oh no.
So, he just came into the bar that I was at.
So, this was, oh no, it was a Friday night, Friday night,
still Shabbat.
But yeah, so it was Friday night,
Second Avenue Deli is closed.
So, he just happened to be right in front of the bar
where I was and that's it.
I mean, it was just, there was no...
It was very calculated,
but the location and the timing was not.
That was complete happen stance.
And yeah, you just find yourself at the wrong place
at the wrong time.
Completely, completely random situation.
And so in the aftermath of this
and then having to get involved as a witness in all of that,
I would imagine that there's a pretty significant
sort of post traumatic stress
that goes hand in hand with that.
I mean, how did you kind of manage the aftermath?
Well, he was tried three times.
I mean, it was, I think,
I'm pretty sure from a legal perspective,
the battle was all related to his mental health
and his defense being insanity.
But I mean, so reliving that each time
and seeing him each time was really,
I mean, it was traumatic for me.
But in dealing with it,
I was entering my senior year at NYU.
I kept thinking, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
And I went to talk therapy for a while,
and it was like speaking to a counselor and whatever,
and I felt okay.
But it wasn't until I started running in law school
that I really started to process all of that,
and in ways that I didn't even realize.
Like, I would just be really running a mile or two, three
that started very, very, very basic,
and I'd think like a random thought would pop
into my head about this man,
or I would have an image of his face at an intersection.
And I'm like, why am I thinking about this dude?
Like, this has been two years later.
And that's when I really started to process it all.
And then I get these abstract questions
and existential questions of like, why am I here?
Am I supposed to be in law school?
And, I don't know.
I mean, it was just like question mark after question mark.
And only like in the past decade
have I slowly sort of been chipping away
at all those answers?
I mean, I think it's a lifetime quest.
The sort of the gift and the experience is
that it catalyzed some self-reflection
and some thinking about like what it is
that you're here to do,
and that kind of has helped craft your redirect, right,
so to speak?
Yeah, yeah.
I think it planted the seed.
I mean, I ended up endeavoring in a seven year law career,
a corporate lawyer,
securities litigation and intellectual property.
I can't believe, I still can't believe.
I'm like, wow, that seems like a lifetime ago,
and it really wasn't.
But I don't regret-
I can't even, I can't even.
Right?
I mean, people who I show up to,
like I show up to meetings in like a sports bra
and booty shorts, and people are like...
You were a what?
And very corporate.
Like, I mean, we represented like fortune 50 companies.
I know, which firm were you at?
I was at Paul Hastings.
My entire career.
Biggest law firms in the world.
Securities, litigation, and like-
And during subprime.
Like, this was like one of the most intense,
I mean, it was like 80 hour weeks,
like just fighting for the banks.
It was so crazy.
But I really kind of relished, like,
I really don't regret one bit,
not one hour I spent in that law firm
because, I mean, it really makes me appreciate my life now,
but I have, I learned so much about business
and intellectual pursuits and just like savvy.
I really became much more savvy from that,
from that part of my career, that part of my life.
So, that transition into now having spandex
as business casual is kind of-
Right, I mean, it's dramatic.
It's dramatic, but it's also like, God, I love it.
I can't even tell you how much-
I mean, were you bringing the swagger
when you were in the law firm?
Or is it pre-swagger days?
No!
Oh come one.
You can't, you can't even-
You can't take the swagger out of Robin.
You can't take the swagger out.
No, but I remember putting on my suits
and putting on my fancy clothes,
and I would get like a manicure and it'd be bright orange,
or I'd be like, you know, going to argue my first motion
and I would have like a three finger ring on.
Like, I always needed like a little something
to show I think myself more than anything else,
to be honest, that I wasn't losing it.
And I often think about the weight.
Like, that suit felt heavy.
And I didn't realize until later
when I was literally shedding all these clothes
that I'm like, damn, that wasn't my gig, man.
Like, it just wasn't.
But I needed to get through that
in order to feel confident enough
to really pursue the things that I'm pursuing now.
And so when you were working in the law firm,
was the running starting to pick up speed?
Were you doing that then?
Yes, so the running, the running picked up speed,
the running paralleled my law career.
So, as I advanced my law career, so did my running as well.
And I went from, you know, classic distances,
you know, 5K, 10K to half marathon, marathon,
then a bunch of marathons, and, you know, then ultras.
But that, I think I only got the courage,
they went hand in hand.
I got the courage to sort of take on bigger projects
and be a little bolder in my law career,
and then simultaneously did that in running.
And then I found that running was so much my passion
that like, I mean, law paled in comparison.
Right, but the empowerment
that you probably were able to develop through the running,
I would imagine that would've sort of assisted you
in your confidence in your law practice, all of that, right?
Without question.
I mean, I even, I think I even learned...
I did.
I learned visualization techniques as a runner
that I would then apply to like,
I remember before going into court to argue my first motion,
I was like sitting on the subway, listening to MIA,
and just like envisioning the success of it.
And that's not like a skill or a tactic I had ever learned.
Like, I didn't know anything about sports psychology
at the time.
And it was all because of, it was a learned skill
that I developed as a runner.
Right, right, right.
So, what was the moment where you decided like,
I'm leaving this path behind?
A few weeks before the London Olympics.
I had the hair-brained idea of going.
And I was like, I'm just gonna pitch a bunch of articles.
And, you know, I knew some Olympic swimmers,
so I was like, I'll pitch an article about them,
and Newsweek and the Daily Beast-
Who are the swimmers that you know?
My friend Azad.
He swims for Syria.
Oh, cool.
He lives in Venice.
I wonder if you guys have ever-
I don't know him.
Yeah, he's amazing.
So, he didn't medal, but I mean, he was,
he refused to walk under the flag
'cause of all the political unrest.
So, and now like Syria has basically dropped him,
so he's funding his own way to Brazil 2016.
So yeah, but I wish, I mean, he's amazing.
I wish him the best.
Cool, he sounds like I should get him
on the podcast.
Yeah, you should.
That'd be an interesting story.
He's a really, really, really,
and he's a young guy.
I mean, he's only like 27.
Wow.
Really engaging guy.
But so through mutual friends, he and I became friendly,
and I was gonna ring him.
And so I ended up pitching a bunch of articles
to different publications, and I was like, eh,
I'm gonna make like all of $300 from this.
But you had already quit the law firm?
No, that was the catalyst.
You were like gonna take your vacation time to-
I was gonna take a,
well, I had taken a leave of absence,
and I had done some traveling
and I was doing some work in Europe,
running a bunch of races.
I did like a bunch of little Nike projects over in Europe.
And I asked to extend my leave,
and they were like, actually, no.
You're welcome to stay or you're welcome to go.
I mean, I was already like a rising eighth year
at this point.
Like, I don't blame them for being like,
are you in or are you out?
Right, right.
So, that was it.
I was like, okay, I'm just gonna book this ticket to London
that costs well more than my rent.
It was so late that that ticket.
Ooh.
But, it all was worth it because it was from,
I mean, I ended up meeting a ton of people
when I was in London,
but it was there that I got the job
on the digital team working with Nike.
Right.
I think that's a great example of how you, you know,
it's kind of scary to take the full leap.
Like, it's, you were in a very secure job.
Very.
Getting like paid really well, you know,
and that's very hard to leave, you know, and to have,
and you were able to kind of still do things
outside of that, so you have one foot in
but kind of one foot out.
I mean, you could have, had they not forced that issue,
you could have perpetuated that for a long time.
Yeah, and I'm really grateful.
You were sort of compelled to make that leap.
But I think that, you know, in terms of,
when you start talking about kind of self-actualization,
or kind of, you know, story, which we're gonna get into,
which is, you know, your theme
and kind of what you speak to,
in order to really embrace that,
like you have to, you have to be all in,
you gotta go all in, right?
Yep.
You were forced to do that
and, you know, have some blind faith.
I mean, to walk away from that
and step into, yeah, I'm gonna write an article,
and get paid 300 bucks.
Yeah, I mean, I don't even know
if it was that much.
It might have been like 100 bucks.
I mean, gosh.
Freelance journalism is a feat.
I wanna spend a ton of money to go to London,
to like not get paid to do something.
(Robin laughs)
Yeah.
Yeah, and I mean, it was, I actually like accidentally,
coincidentally met the CEO of Nike, Mark Parker, in London.
And he and I both happened to be in a Nike store.
And I was like, whatever, I'm just gonna go up
and talk to this guy.
So, I was telling him my story
and how, you know, I was, you know,
really appreciative of the brand
and I dabbled and done this or that for the brand.
And, you know, he turns to me and he goes,
I thought about going to law school.
If I had gone to law school,
those pair of shoes right there would never have happened.
And I was like, dude, that's amazing.
And I just felt like this like cosmic stamp of approval
on my decision.
And then he turns to me, and he is like,
you have really good style, you should start a blog.
I was like, funny, you say that 'cause I have one.
And I handed him my business card.
Nothing ever happened from that.
But, you know, it was like those little moments of boldness.
You have to celebrate those victories.
Well, and also he's giving you a pat on the back.
He's saying, you know, he's kind of saying,
he's sort of like, you know, keep going, grasshopper.
Yeah, yeah.
It was like, I felt like was like a little pat on the head,
like just go forth and conquer your little area of grass.
And so what was the next step?
I mean, you're like, you must have come back to New York
and kind of went, all right,
like how am I gonna make this work?
Well, I actually ended up getting a job offer
before I even came back from the Olympics.
So, I was in London for three weeks,
and then somebody at an agency who does work with Nike,
they hired me for the Nike Women's team.
And I thought I had my dream job.
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm gonna write copy
and be a creative sort of voice for this brand
and women in fitness.
And I realized really quickly,
really quickly that I didn't wanna write under anybody
behind anybody else's brand or voice.
In conjunction with, yes.
But not behind.
You know, I was sort of this anonymous copywriter,
social media person and that's not really who I am.
Anonymously advancing somebody else's brand.
You're telling somebody else's story really.
Yeah, I'm being paid, basically,
you know, my urban athletic experience,
which is unique is then, you know, sort of appropriated,
and I'm not-
For somebody else's bank.
For somebody, yeah, yeah.
Build your own dreams
or somebody will hire you to build theirs.
Right.
So, all right, so then in light of that,
like so how does it go from there?
So from there, so when I left the agency,
I was really kind of at a crossroads.
I'm like, what do I even do? How do I make money?
So, I had already been coaching some folks, some runners,
and then I started taking brand consulting gigs.
So, I was like, all right, I know about this space.
I understand business.
I understand social media marketing.
So, now I've worked with almost every major athletic brand
as a consultant.
So, what kind of thing,
like what do you bring to that?
Like, when they say, they come to you and they say,
help us figure out how we're gonna position this brand
or portray it, or like what kind of counsel are you giving?
It's on two ends.
Sometimes it's on the product side.
It's just like, does this even fly aesthetically, you know,
product and styling.
And sometimes it's just marketing.
It's like, how do we message to X, Y, or Z demo?
And I happen to represent like a few demographics.
You're like the go-to person.
Like, we wanna penetrate like cool chicks in urban-
Yeah.
And especially, especially a few years ago, it was like,
you know, a lot of that cool gear really wasn't around,
and brands are scrambling realizing that this fitness,
that sweat is a lifestyle.
It's no longer necessarily like the Lululemon yoga mom.
It's like a whole, it's a very rich, vibrant community
of all kinds of stuff.
And I'm part of an urban running crew movement
that really embraces the 360 kind of mash up of culture
and sweat and style and fashion.
And we just did it organically as a lived experience,
like running to an art show
and then running from there to like a DJ set
and then like, you know,
waking up and doing it all over again.
And, you know, wearing a sports bra to the club.
Like, my fitness, I founded a fitness collective
called Undo Ordinary.
And, you know, we throw a Friday night party,
and it's like, come in your sports bra.
Like, you are like, leave your stilettos at home.
We're not into that.
Yeah, yeah, 'cause your whole thing is like,
you look like you could either be going
to work out right now or you're going out.
There's not like a distinction.
Thank you!
I mean, that's exactly what we want.
That's what I want.
Yeah, very cool.
Well, I would imagine a lot of that comes into, you know,
how you style the specific, you know, photograph
that is gonna be in the magazine,
that's gonna speak to that, right?
Yeah.
Is that something that you...
Styling?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I've definitely done styling before.
Cool.
And I love that.
But the problem is, you know,
what you mentioned before about, you know,
the gray shorts and the navy, you know, the navy palette,
there's still such a hesitance to just go in
for what the minority
that's pushing the boundaries of aesthetic and sport
and this movement, what I consider a movement,
a lifestyle movement,
there's still hesitancy to like really go there
with product.
Right, because, well, what I would think is
there aren't that many people that can pull off your look,
you know what I mean?
In real life.
You know what I mean?
So, it's a distinction between like aspirational
and like the reality of doing commerce.
Right, right.
And you know, and that's a balance that, you know-
Like, you go to like a runway show
or like the pictures in Vogue magazine
that are so styled, like, no one's actually gonna wear that.
Right, like who's gonna wear
like the million dollar couture dress, right, I get it.
But it captures your imagination
and you sort of, you know, you can fancy it
and you can aspire to that,
and it speaks to like a lifestyle or an aesthetic, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I agree, and I definitely see that,
but I think with respect to running and cycling
and all these other modalities,
it's a little more down to earth
where like I just think people have
to expand their comfort levels a little more,
and I think there's a messaging particularly
to women about how they should feel
in a certain type of clothing for working out.
And I think people just need to feel confident
in being a little bolder in their aesthetic.
What do you think,
like what is the biggest impediment with respect to women
and fitness that you try to speak to?
Oh God.
I think the majority of messaging to women is wrapped
in pink and diluted.
I don't think that...
It's changing, it's changing.
I think the rhetoric is changing a little bit.
But I don't think the sort of aggressive
like balls to the wall messaging that has been, you know,
with men in sports forever has really entered the space
for female athletes.
And I think people are even hesitant
to call themselves athletes.
I'm an indoor cycling instructor,
and I have women in my classes who go hard.
I mean, they train like with me five days a week.
Really, really like working hard.
And I'm like, you're an athlete.
And they're like, no, I'm not.
And I'm like, yeah, you are, dude.
Like, you're a fucking athlete.
And so I think that's a mental shift,
and it's a different type of empowerment.
Right, trying to kind of own the masculine aspect
of this ying and yang in a certain respect, right?
Like, instead of being like,
oh, doesn't she look cute in her shorts
and, you know, her trainers, her tennies.
You know what I mean?
And, you know, I say,
I often say nothing cute, nothing comfortable.
Like, we are smashing comfort zones here,
and I don't care how sexy
or cute you think you look doing it,
you're gonna use every bead of sweat to become the badass
that you saw in that magazine or you saw in that show.
Like, I wanna think
that people can become their own inspiration
and then push that forward,
so you're just starting this movement of people
who feel absolutely enraptured
and passionate about whatever.
I don't care if it's like, you know,
you're proud for packing your kid's lunch
or like you just landed like the sickest, you know, CEO gig.
Like, all of that.
The panoply of it is just as important
if it's meaningful to you.
I think that transcends-
That's true empowerment, right?
Exactly.
From the ground up.
Yeah.
So, walk me through a day in the life.
Ooh, there is-
'Cause you're all over the place.
Like, I'm like what is going on?
So, I teach, what is today?
So yesterday, Monday.
I teach, I taught three spin classes before 9:00 AM.
(Robin laughs)
Which studio, where is that?
I teach at two studios, one at Peloton,
which is a really exciting new fitness concept.
It's kind of like the Netflix of cycling.
Peloton is a bike that has a console on it,
and we live stream classes from our studio in New York City
all around the world.
Oh, wow.
So, that's really neat.
And then I have another local studio called Revolve
in Union Square that I love.
I love my riders there.
And so, I'll teach three classes in the morning,
go home, eat like everything in sight, like as much,
I eat like more kale than I can, yeah,
like my weight in kale pretty much.
And then yesterday I ended up having a meeting
about the magazine that I'm launching.
I'm the editor in chief of Undo Ordinary Magazine,
which is launching this summer.
Cool.
Wait, hold on a second.
Like, you can't just gloss over that.
You're like launching a magazine.
Yeah, so I co-founded a fitness collective
called Undo, and the whole idea
behind it was this whole empowerment thing
we're talking about like
how ordinary people can do extraordinary things,
like undoing a lot of the sort of self-loathing
and limiting beliefs that irrespective of gender we all have
and providing not only a training platform
and a lived aesthetic
but kind of holding space
for these amazing sweat inducing endorphin moments.
So, like we just wanna take,
we literally just wanna take over the world with sweat
and do it with swagger.
So, that's Undo as a movement,
and then we kind of put that visually
and substantively into a magazine.
And so, it's gonna be a quarterly magazine,
and my friend Sophia Chang
who's a really, really well known graphic designer,
you know, it has her stamp on it all throughout the pages,
and Nai Vasha is my business partner.
She's sort of, she calls herself a mood creator.
So, she does, you know, anything from video work,
she's long, long history in the music industry.
And so, all three of us kind of
like are bringing our respective wheelhouses to the table
and it's, that's it,
it's a living mashup of all these things.
Wow.
And do you, you have like a partner
who's been in the magazine business,
who understands how to do that?
'Cause like that just seems like a huge-
Yeah, I mean, it's a serious endeavor.
Well, so Urban Outfitters has a new division
called Without Walls,
and Without Walls is a sponsor of the magazine
and the sponsor of Undo.
So, one of the people who we're working with
at Without Walls actually has a former magazine background.
That's a plus.
But I mean, this has been like a pure labor of love,
like we've made mistakes and then remade mistakes,
and, you know, so we're gonna make many more,
but we were like, we wanna get this out there.
And MTV just recently sort of picked up this whole story.
So, MTV Voices recently filmed us and is developing,
you know, some content around what Undo is
and what it means to the fitness world
and the wellness movement.
So yeah, I had a meeting.
I had to look over like the final, you know,
PDF of the issue.
Sign on that-
So, when's it gonna drop?
July, it should be by July 31st.
So, we're literally sending it to print today.
And will it be in Urban Outfitter stores?
Yeah, it'll be in Urban stores.
It will be, we have a bunch of distributors worldwide,
a lot of like small sportswear shops,
like Black Rainbow in Paris, you know,
little places, really just through friends,
and we're just like, you wanna carry our magazine?
(everyone laughs)
So, it's just, I mean, the hustle is real, man.
The hustle is real.
And it's honestly not to make,
I mean, we're gonna make some money,
but we're donating a large part of the money we make
actually to Girls Gotta Run,
which is a nonprofit in Ethiopia that provides young girls
from like nine to 18 with running gear and training camps,
and yeah, we officially partner with them.
And yeah, it's so much more than like a dollar.
Right, right, right.
It's service.
For sure.
It's a movement.
It's a movement that nourishes me so deeply, I...
To be even a participant in the conversation,
let alone like call myself someone
who's pushing the conversation forward, is a real honor.
And thankfully social media makes it possible.
You know, we have little things like hashtag campaigns.
And now when I search Undo Ordinary,
I'm like not even a year ago,
this was just like a concept in my mind.
And now I have people I'm connected with
from Russia to India.
I mean, they're writing to me the most like humbling,
profound notes.
And I'm like, A, you did that,
B, wow.
There's nothing I can really say.
So, yeah, typical day, that,
and then I had a photo shoot.
And I went from there to a photo shoot,
answered some emails, tweets, Instagram.
God, this rabbit hole of social media.
You're your own walking reality show really.
(Robin laughs)
I mean, they're so,
you know, probably had a fight with my boyfriend,
and then I taught three more classes.
So, yeah, I taught six classes.
Oh, and then I went on my own run.
Yeah, so it's like,
normally it's like five to six classes a day,
six to 10 miles and business.
Hustle.
Filling it in.
I bet every day's pretty much different
except you're probably teaching classes in some respect
or another.
Yeah, I teach 22 classes a week.
Wow.
Yeah, what part of town do you live in?
I live downtown.
I wouldn't go above Houseton Street if I had a choice.
(Robin laughs)
So this is of privilege.
This is luxury right here to go above.
I'd actually much prefer to be downtown,
but I also like running in the park.
Yeah, I mean, listen,
like I get the draw to nature,
and I showed up to my first trail race,
like my first trail race actually ever,
literally ever running on a trail was a 50 miler.
(Robin laughs)
I went to REI, and I was like, oh, I need some shoes to run
in the wilderness.
So, thankfully I got something with a rock plate
'cause oh my God, it was crazy.
So, I get it, I really do.
Like, I nourish that in me, but when I'm in New York,
like I feel truly like I'm pushing the pulse of the city
when I run the bridges, the streets, Brooklyn, like-
It's urban trail running.
It is.
It's like, can I spot like a new graffiti piece?
You know, and I might know the artist,
you know, that's like, it's a different kind of excavation.
Right, well, I find, and I like doing that too.
And when I stay downtown that's exactly what I do
and I love it.
And it's like when I'm at home, I'm running trails
and there's like a kind of an active meditation
kind of aspect to that.
But the visual stimulation of running in New York,
I mean, even when you're running in the park,
it's just constant people watching.
You know, it's just fascinating.
It's so, I always run harder and longer and faster
in New York City than I do elsewhere
because it's just, there's so much energy.
You know, you take that energy on
and just running through the streets and it's so fun.
Like, it's my, like it's weird.
Like, you know, I love trail running,
but I think New York City is like one of my favorite places
to run because it's so unique in that regard.
And you never run out of interesting things to see.
And you're just constantly like being enriched
by the experience of just the visual palette
of what this city has to offer.
It's like a game of Frogger.
It is.
It's a video game.
It's totally like a video game.
Yeah, I'm like running,
like trying not to get run over by taxi cabs.
Same thing, like biking through the city. I mean, I love it.
Yeah, and it's not like, oh, there's a stoplight.
We have to stop.
Like, damn.
It's like, no, this is part of it.
Like, this is part of the game, you know, of doing this.
So, I wanna hear like a little bit about like,
'cause it's all about like the urban experience for you
of running, right?
And you've created like this cultish, you know,
movement around this.
So, like speak to that a little bit.
I mean, when I moved back from law school,
I was in law school.
I was in Philadelphia for law school,
moved back to New York City, and I was a solo runner,
and I really didn't know what it felt like
to be part of a community.
I'd never been part of team sports.
And I showed up one day to this downtown running crew
called Bridge Runners.
And I was like, oh man, I found like my people,
I found like my weirdos.
They're like not traditional athletes.
Nobody was a former track star.
I mean, they're like,
I mean, God, some of them smoke more weed
than is humanly possible.
And it's like, I was like, cool.
I found like my Motley Crew.
And miles and miles and miles and like bonded by sweat.
We became a family.
And then we realized there were little families
all over the place.
And now we have like friends who are crews in London
and Paris.
And we are just
like this really rich international community of runners
who are kind of off the beaten track.
I mean, it was like, we just-
You know what it is, like it's-
So rogue, you know,
it's like the "Warriors" movie.
I was gonna say-
That's what it's like.
It's like "Warriors" or like "West Side Story."
I see your Instagram feed and I'm like, it's this gang,
you know, you're running in New York City.
I was like, this is like some weird choreographed,
like "West Side Story."
We're gonna start snapping,
you know, snapping choreography.
Yeah, I mean, but there's this herd...
Herd mentality in a good way.
Not in a following, not in a sheepish way,
but in a way that's like,
yeah, you're not going anywhere, taxi.
Like, we're taking this light.
And we're, it's just, we literally take over the streets.
I mean, hundreds deep sometimes on a run.
And we become part of the fabric of New York City
in a very real way.
I mean, people are just like, whoa, what was that?
Like, it's just a force.
And I never felt that before.
And then, so from there meeting all these other crews
and then sort of starting my own movement,
which has taken it now outside of running
into other modalities
and then bringing in the fashion element
and the lifestyle element,
and it just sparked, it sparked something like,
I don't even know where I got this quote,
some really profound, prolific author, I'm sure.
But it's, you know, I think it's Rumi.
"Seeking out people who fan your flames."
And I'm like, God, I was engulfed.
And I was so passionate from these experiences
that it got to the point where I was leading a double life.
Like, I would just wait all day to make it to the run.
And thankfully, most of the runs were later at night,
like total night owls, so I was able to make it
when I was a lawyer.
I'm like, I can't do this anymore.
Like, I've just gotta find a way to pay my rent doing this.
And somehow I've been able to, you know-
And there's no path.
No, there's no path.
There wasn't even anybody I could talk to.
Like, it wasn't like there was somebody high up
who I just had to like tap into their knowledge.
Like, I didn't know anything about this space as a business.
And the business as a business was sort of was born
out of these experiences.
Like, really Bridge Runners is one of the first
if not the first New York City running crew
as like that vernacular has now come to be.
And crew differing from a club
in that a club is like a training group
and a crew is like this family, this gang, this,
it's not what happens on Tuesday night at the run,
but it's what happens Wednesday morning at the club,
or Saturday at the Christening.
You know, it's, yeah, yeah.
It extends beyond that,
beyond the run that you're doing, right.
Absolutely.
Into your whole,
like woven into your entire lifestyle.
Yeah, it's kind of like this,
this ethos driven training style
where you're not really doing it.
You're not necessarily doing it for the finish line.
You're doing it like to make the family proud.
I don't know.
Yeah, I mean,
I think it's like an analogy would be, you know,
you're on a diet to lose weight,
to hit some specific weight, you know,
but it's not a lifestyle.
It's not what you live and breathe.
It's a temporary thing.
Or training for a race so that you can qualify
for another race or get your best time.
Like, it's not really about that.
It's about the day to day experience of what you're living
and breathing by being part of this crew, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
And I really, I like to lead a life
where there really is no finish line.
Like, finish lines are great.
Like, don't get me wrong,
I'm definitely competitive with myself.
And I love a PR, all that jazz.
But it's kind of like raising the bar
and then taking it to the next level
and then harnessing the power of community to do that.
And I think that is the, for me,
that's been the perfect recipe for the catalyst
to my success.
Right, like raising the bar for the weakest member
of the crew.
Yeah, no runner left behind.
Like, that is like a refrain that you'll always hear.
'Cause people are always like,
oh, we see these pictures and you guys look so rad
and badass and I'm like, you're gonna be fine.
Like, trust me.
Like, the fastest runner in the group
at some point has been the slowest runner.
Like, it's just the way evolution works.
But you've also had some badass finish lines.
Yeah, you know, it's been fun.
So, let's talk about some of these epic runs
that you've done.
God, I love running.
I just do.
I just love it.
I'm like I wanna go run right now.
Yeah, I think, so I've done some trail races,
some 50 milers.
I think the most,
definitely the most humbling thing I've done, and I,
you know, I really want, have you run across the country?
No.
I really wanna run,
there's something like lodged in the back of my brain
about that, but that's an aside.
So, I think last summer I was running across Utah.
I did five, it was kind of like set up like a stage race.
I did five marathons in five days
to raise money for MS Run the US.
My mom has MS.
And my very, very first marathon I signed up for
after a breakup (laughs) and I was like,
my mom wasn't doing well
and she was having a lot of issues with her MS.
And I was like, I gotta do something.
And so I signed, that's how my first marathon came to be.
And then from there I was just like,
okay, I need more and more and more of this.
But the running across Utah as part of that relay team was,
I didn't understand until then the mental game
that was required as an endurance athlete.
I prepared myself for physical discomfort.
I did all like the two a days, 100 mile weeks.
I mean, I've never run more in my life
than preparing for that.
And because people were donating,
I felt even more pressure to like, I have to do it.
I'm telling people and asking people to give me money,
I've gotta do this thing.
So yeah, I started at one point in Utah
and finished at the other point,
and then passed on the baton to the next runner.
So I'm like, you know-
So it was a relay across America
where each person got a certain distance
that they had to cover.
Yeah, point to point.
Most people, I actually did the least amount of miles.
I think some folks did like nine straight marathons or more.
Who got like Nebraska?
God, I don't know.
I don't know how I got Utah, man.
Like, you know, it's funny 'cause the relay was ending
right around Labor Day, and I go to Burning Man every year,
and I was like,
and I really wanted the New Jersey, New York leg
'cause then all my crew could come out and whatever.
And I was like, all right,
this is gonna be pretty much a solo venture then
'cause I'm going to Utah.
I don't know how many people I can get to come with me.
(Robin laughs)
No, but it was, I mean,
you'd think I'd be like taking in the majestic mountains
and like, I was like, screw that mountain.
I have to run up it like.
Thankfully, so there was a documentary film crew there
capturing the whole thing
and there's a documentary coming out next year,
sort of about my journey and my relationship with my mom
and like the hostage thing
and just, I mean, I guess like largely
about my life path so far,
and they were there to capture it.
So, I'm really grateful that they have that footage
'cause now I can, now I just saw the trailer and I'm like,
ah, that's really beautiful.
I'm glad I did that.
But in the moment you're just like so mired
and like the rawness of the experience and the pain,
but it was-
What was the hardest part of that run?
Mentally, it was just waking up every day
and doing it again.
Like, I would wake up
and I'd be like, no way I'm gonna do that again.
And really after the fifth, I could have kept going.
I mean, physically, I was truly fine.
I'd done plenty of training.
It was just that little voice inside saying like,
you can't do this.
And it was just all like an internal conversation
that was mind blowing to me
'cause I'm like I have visualized this and prepared
and like read all the books
and it was like, you can't prepare for the moments
when you're gonna be your worst critic.
And it was just like standing on the side of the road.
I had a total like diva Beyonce moment
on the side of the road,
there were like 18 wheelers passing by,
and I was like, I just had a breakdown.
I was like, I'm unsafe.
This is like messed up.
And I'm like, you're stronger than this.
Like, buck up.
Like, you almost died at the end of a gun.
How many marathons in were you when that happened?
That was on my last day.
That was my last 10 miles.
And-
Ready to throw it in.
No, and it was like totally illogical,
but it was like in those moments you become a two year old.
Like, you are just like an infant,
like and nobody can tell you otherwise.
And I think I've definitely like, you know,
I've crewed some friends,
and I've seen, I've seen that in other runners
and I'm like, okay, I wasn't alone.
Like, that was like, I was like hallucinating,
and, you know, it was just crazy.
Yeah.
And that's why they say never have your friends
or people you care about crew for you
because you really, you, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's an intense.
You know, you've been there.
It's an intense-
It's not pretty, you know what I mean?
I talk about it in my book.
It's like you start are behaving in a way
that you're not proud of.
No, no.
And your stripped raw.
There's nothing there, you know?
And that's where you really meet your maker.
Yeah.
And you're, I mean, you're lacing up and it's like,
who really, who are you really?
And I was like, it was not, it was not pretty,
it was not pretty at the side of that road.
But to be able to push, but to push through that,
that's where like you talk about like these, you know,
empowerment.
I mean, that moment is the moment,
like all the other marathons leading up to that was all
for that.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And I had a really hard race in San Diego recently.
I was one minute off of BQ in Vermont,
and the next week I was running San Diego,
and I just happened to,
and I got the opportunity to run Vermont.
San Diego was really my goal race.
And I like looked at the elevation,
and I'm like, oh, it's gonna be fine.
Mile 21, I just like,
oh, and like six, eight weeks ago I was diagnosed
with type one diabetes.
Yeah, I know.
We're gonna get into that.
But anyways, but I had a crash,
but like the crashes with type one are
like a crash times a billion.
Like, it's just like you,
I was gonna start like just clawing up the highway.
I mean, it was bad.
So, this of course is a mile ascent
up this like fricking freeway in San Diego.
And I just, and that was like my second,
it brought me right back to like that moment in Utah
where I was like, I can't do this anymore.
And then I had to just be like, deal with it, dude.
You're not gonna BQ, you're not gonna get your best race.
Just finish the finish line
for the satisfaction of finishing what you started.
And yeah, it was kind of amazing to, in the,
I liked the process of being able
to recognize the disappointment, deal with it,
get rid of it, and just keep it going.
And then, you know, a little Gatorade helped too.
(Robin laughs)
That would help.
I mean, do you have these mornings where you're just,
you wake up and you're like, can't do it today.
Like, I'm just beat, I'm tired.
Oh my God, I'm tired so much.
People think, oh, you're doing all this stuff,
like you must just have the energy.
I mean, I don't drink coffee.
I'm not a caffeine person.
I just, I try to, you know, put in, you know,
what I think is gonna fuel my body the best
and that's not processed stuff.
But yes, I absolutely have those mornings
where I'm like, oh, I don't have it in me.
But then I think about how I'm gonna feel on the other end.
And that's always so nourished.
Like, before, so I'll wake up to teach my 6:00 AM classes
and I'm like, not today, man.
And then I leave those classes and it's like one rider
or one moment in the ride when everything comes together,
and I know that I'm putting out something into the world
that like is really authentic
and hopefully meaningful to someone.
So thinking it through to its conclusion, sort of.
Yeah, I always, even before a workout,
like I know before, like a really tough workout,
really tough run, or something like cross training,
I'm like, I don't wanna do this,
but I know how gratifying it's gonna feel.
Even if the workout wasn't what I expected,
it's always worth it.
Yeah, well, I think it's important
to communicate that because I think it would be easy
for somebody listening to this going,
well, she's just full of energy.
Like, that's not me.
I can't do that.
She's a freak of nature.
I mean, doing all this kind of stuff,
but, you know, this is not,
it's not like you've been doing this your whole life either.
Not even!
Like, not even a few years.
Like, this is just like-
Wait, how many years ago did you quit the law firm?
Two.
Oh, it's only been two. Oh my God.
(everyone laughs)
Two years.
It just seems like that must have been
like 10 years ago at least.
No, no.
I mean, this is like,
truly, I like just was like, I'm a consultant,
I'm an ultra marathoner.
I've just like created these titles for myself
and then like, well, did the work
and then created the title.
You have to act as if.
Yeah, fake it 'til you make it.
And then now it's like a thing.
(Robin laughs)
I'm sure you have,
you probably have young women come up to you all the time,
like, how did you do what you do?
Like, you know, what kind of advice do you give out
to people that aspire to your lifestyle
or to just, you know, because I think, you know,
what you exude also is, you know,
aside from empowerment is like freedom, you know.
I think, oh God.
The biggest piece of advice my mother ever gave me was
to stay weird.
Like, I think we have such a tendency,
we as a society, everyone has, we wanna feel included.
And I think we do that sometimes
by sacrificing parts of ourselves.
And we don't even realize it.
It's like an unconscious submission
to other people's standards.
And I mean, in a society that's inevitably gonna happen,
but you have to realize what the kernels are inside
and be like, that's a non-negotiable piece.
And I was really negotiating too much of myself away
when I was a lawyer, but I didn't realize it at the time.
And I think people are living at sort of like,
I think there's this pervasive, like malaise,
like people are living at like a 50%
and they're just okay with it.
Like, okay, isn't okay.
Like, you can actually be happy with the choices
that you make and the life that you're leading
if you evaluate what's really important to you.
Like, what are your triggers?
What's your passion?
And I'm really fortunate that running unlocked that for me.
But, you know, people do ask me all the time,
like how do I find that for me?
And I think it's not,
things that you're excited about that's not accidental.
Like, figure out a way to marry your skillset
with that thing that like makes you wanna wake up every day,
even if you were doing it for free.
And like really I would be doing the work I do now for free,
if I could, if I could afford it.
You know?
And I think that that's the stuff, like that's life.
Right, I mean, I think it's like a,
well, first of all,
you know, we're all just plugged into a certain way of life.
You know, it's like we're on this treadmill
of like the way that things are supposed to be.
And so we're not really compelled, you know,
we're not really encouraged I guess I should say
to look within at all really.
It's not really part of the Western culture of prerogative.
So, there's that.
And then we're all trying to fit in, like you said,
so that doesn't encourage individuality or staying weird
or kind of expressing what's authentic
and unique to yourself.
We're kind of, you know, programmed to do the opposite,
which is to repress that.
And so, after years and years and years of doing that,
it's almost flip for somebody to say,
well, like live your passion.
It's like most people are walking around,
like they're so disconnected from who they are,
that you can't even begin to answer that question.
Like, that question comes much later.
You know, there has to be a first step in
at least trying to develop a better relationship
with yourself so that you can start to delve into that
and figure out what that is.
Because I know a lot of people who are like,
well, I would do something I was passionate about
if I knew what I was passionate about.
Like, I don't even know because, and it's not their fault,
you know, and I know what that's like,
I've been in that place.
I don't, you know, I didn't know what I wanted to do or be
or what was unique about me at all.
You know, I was just doing what was in front of me to do.
And it's very, very difficult, you know?
So, like, what is the,
and I'm sure you've encountered lots of people like this,
so like what is that first step that somebody can do?
I think...
Well, actually, one thing.
I think it's helpful to notice
when you're jealous of someone because-
That's really interesting.
It means they probably have something you want.
Yeah, jealousy really speaks more about you than,
it's all about you.
Yes, yes.
And I noticed like, I know for me,
I would look at, you know, people in the fitness movement
who have made careers out of it,
and I'm like, man, they get paid for that.
I wanna get paid for that!
And it was like this little pang of like desire
and jealousy, like, and not in like a romantic jealousy way,
but, you know, in a substantive like, God, I want that,
like a yearning.
And we should pay attention to that stuff.
I think one of the first things
that we can do is really pay attention
to our inner monologue.
And I believe in,
like most of the things I've done in business,
it's only been a few years so my journey's just starting,
but it's all based on a gut check.
It's like pure am I feeling you or this or not?
And if it's not, like you're out of my sphere, man.
Like, I have no time-
But you gotta be,
you have to be clear before you can trust a gut check.
Yeah, exactly. So, you have to clear it out.
And I actually think-
'Cause your gut check will send you
down a dark alleyway if you don't know who you are,
you know what I mean?
Very true.
That gut check could be jealousy.
Like, you're confusing these conflicting emotions.
Right, right, right, absolutely.
Well, one thing that has helped me is meditation.
I practice-
This is what I was driving at anyway.
Okay, I'm with you.
So, I dabbled in so many types of meditation, man.
I mean, like, it's super,
it was super, super, super hard for me.
Like, that's not my natural frequency.
Like, I'm not like-
Yeah, you're vibrating at two,
you're at like 3,000 Herz or whatever.
I'm like a living earthquake.
So, you know, I tried guided meditation
and like, you know, Gabriel Bernstein podcasts
and like all kinds of stuff, which were fine.
But what really helped me was transcendental meditation.
So, 20 minutes in the morning, 20 minutes in the evening,
and it's a mantra based meditation.
So, I went to this like little course with this guy,
actually a former attorney who I used to work with
who's now a meditation guru, Ben Turshen.
And Ben gave me my mantra, and that's it.
I mean, it was like having that focal point,
having that like instrument for thinking,
which is literally what a mantra means,
let me suspend all this other stuff.
Not like I think this mantra and no thoughts come in.
I think that's the cool thing about this type of meditation
that works for me is that like you allow the thoughts
and then let them go.
And then it's just like this passing thing.
And somehow there's like,
I carve out like this white noise in those 20 minutes
and it works for me, man.
It just totally works.
How long have you been doing that?
Not that long.
I mean, I've been meditating for over a year,
but again, dabbling in all different types of stuff.
So, I would say probably for like four months,
like a dedicated TM practice.
Like, morning and you're hitting it like every day,
20 minutes in the morning and 20 minutes-
Yeah, yeah.
I skipped two days.
I skipped two days last week and I was like,
and you feel it,
like, it's almost like if your body's like craving,
like if you're dehydrated and you want water,
like when you start, when you habituate meditation,
like your body's like, something's wrong, like you need it.
Right, right, right.
And yeah.
Wow, cool.
Yeah, I mean, I just came from interviewing Dan Harris,
the "Nightline" guy, "Good Morning America" guy,
and so I've just been talking meditation like all day,
you know?
Do you meditate?
Yeah, well, my experience has been erratic,
you know, and now I'm on like a really good streak
where I've been doing it like really consistently
for a month, but I've been doing 20 minutes in the morning,
but I haven't gotten to the point
where I'm doing it at night yet.
But I mean, I can definitely, it's made a huge impact on me.
And in the past, I'll do it for a while and I'll stop
and I'll do it for a while.
And I've been really thinking a lot about like,
why do I go in and out of it?
And what are the impediments to just creating
that kind of momentum and consistency?
I don't know that I have the answer to that,
but all I know is that it is working really well right now.
So, I'm getting more and more into it
and interested in hearing more about it.
But it was great to hear Dan's perspective
as being somebody who is such a skeptic, you know,
just really just, you know,
did not want this to be his answer
and for him to kind of discover it
and what it's done to his life
and his ability to kind of speak to it in a way
that is really, is really powerful
because he can connect with people
that ordinarily would not come across it.
So, but he was saying that literally he's like,
just do five minutes, that's it.
Because it's more important that it's doable
and that you do it
than you hit some kind of number about how long it is,
which I thought was interesting.
That's very true.
Especially for people that are beginning,
but he's like, just set your intention
that you're gonna do five minutes.
If you go over, that's fine.
But like, don't create a rule around that.
Just make sure that, 'cause everybody has five minutes.
So, you can't create that excuse of like,
oh, I don't have time.
Yeah, and I think another thing that's interesting
about the, does he practice TM or vedic?
No, no, no.
Well, that type of meditation,
and I'm sure there are many like names for it,
it's also not ritualized in any way.
So, it's not that you have to be on the cushion
in your home doing the thing.
Right, we were talking about that too.
I mean, I've done it on the subway
or, you know, anywhere, planes.
You know, anywhere that you can close your eyes
and I'd stick in my headphones and I don't play anything,
but it's almost like just the people blocker.
(Robin laughs)
And yeah, I mean, you just, it's a portable thing.
You just need you.
Yeah, and I mean, I think that
if you're not kind of looking inward in that way,
then when you're asking yourself these important questions,
like what should I do with my life?
Where do I want to invest all?
I mean, these are huge questions
that can change the trajectory of everything
that you're doing.
Like, you better make sure that you're dialed up
so that you're making the right choice
and that you can rely on your instincts.
I mean, you know, when I was out partying
and drinking all the time,
like, oh, well my instinct says do this,
but that's a terrible instinct.
Right!
That's a bad move, right.
So, like the gut check is good
if you're like doing the work, the inside work.
Yeah, I agree.
But you gotta get to that point.
But I do think that, you know,
barring sort of the big, the big mistake gut check,
you know, gut feelings, people are scared of failing.
And I think people need to get a little bit more comfortable
with failure.
I think if something feels scary to me,
and I can rationalize reasons
why it's not particularly harmful, I usually do it
because I think that fear can be a really good form of fuel
to do stuff.
And of course that's all that's balanced with like,
you know, using rational thoughts
to not put yourself in danger, but-
Well, I think it's okay to be afraid of failing,
but doing it anyway, you know what I mean?
It's sort of like acting as if in the face of that
and being willing to fail,
like embracing, you know, that failure is part of growth.
Like, if you're not like failing all the time at whatever,
then you're not pushing yourself hard enough to, you know,
to expand.
Yeah, I mean, I think that the complacency
and the feeling, if you're feeling comfortable all the time,
you probably need to be doing some more exciting shit.
Right.
Well, I think people that feel comfortable all the time
probably are not very happy.
Yeah, I mean, it goes back to like that 50%.
Like, you're just, okay.
You know, it's not necessarily like a clinical depression
or there's no, there's no real low.
But if you're like in that just mediocre state,
like, release it, release that mediocrity,
like there's so much out there that can really nourish you.
And then you can give that forward to the world.
Like, I don't know. I feel so much about like energy
and like giving rawness and authenticity out
in whatever form that means for you that's productive.
And I think people have a tendency
to just go about their days
and clocking like, oh, it's Monday or, oh, it's Tuesday.
Like, no.
Like, dude, the party doesn't have to continue
for you to keep dancing.
Like, just keep doing your damn thing.
And, I understand that people who are like,
oh, but I don't know what that is.
So, then like keep going back to point A and point B
and hitting refresh.
Like, it's not like, you know, I figured out,
oh, I like this, so that's just gonna be my thing forever.
Like, it's an iterative process.
Like, I might decide next week that I need to reset.
And like, and you just keep doing it.
And it's like that circuitous process
to quote unquote "success" or quote unquote "happiness."
It's showing up to that thing every day
and continuing that process, you know?
Yeah, I mean,
success is not a destination oriented thing.
It's how are you living and breathing
in each moment of your day, you know,
and are you embracing the journey that you're on,
and are you kind of waking up, you know,
excited for what the day might bring you?
I mean, that's success.
And, you know, listen,
I'm sure we both know wildly successful, you know,
rich people that are really unhappy
who have pursued happiness in the form
that, you know, was portrayed to us as the path to,
you know, all of that and then getting there and going,
you know, what the fuck?
This is not what I thought it would be.
And that creates like this crazy existential crisis
where you're like, well, what now?
You know, like everything I did was to get to this thing
and now, well maybe if I just, if I get the next car
or whatever it is that will solve it,
and then doing that enough to understand like,
oh, that's never gonna work.
Now what?
Yeah, and I know that
that's a common sort of like American story
or Western story.
And I just totally can't relate to that anymore.
Like, sometimes it's hard for me to advise on that
or breaking out of that.
But you must have seen partners in your law firm.
Oh yeah, no.
Who are wildly overpaid or not overpaid,
but just incredibly well paid, working incredible hours.
And it's not like when you make partner,
like, oh, they give you the key to the executive washroom
and it's all good.
Like, it's just more work and more responsibility.
And then, and a lot of, you know,
I don't regret my life as a corporate lawyer either.
Like, I learned a lot.
I met amazing brilliant people,
but it was definitely not the life for me.
And I saw a lot of unhappy people who, you know,
medicated themselves through buying things,
always kind of living just a little bit
beyond what they could afford.
So, you're perpetually enslaved
and you're really never able to part with it,
like you're shackled to it.
Oh yeah.
And I remember, I mean, I was gonna,
it was like what the young associates were doing.
People were buying a property,
and I was like, all right, I should buy an apartment, right?
That's what makes sense.
Like, I should move in with this guy,
and we should buy an apartment,
and I should have a kid, right?
And then it's like, no joke,
it was the night before I was supposed to sign the contract
on this apartment, I was like, but it's a great deal,
and it's in Williamsburg,
and it's up and coming and blah, blah, blah.
I was like, what are you doing?
You're gonna be shackled with a mortgage,
and you don't even want this job.
And that was two years before I actually left.
And it took two years to build the courage.
So, I don't say like, flippantly,
like, ah, just like quit your job and like do epic things.
Like, I get it.
These are hard things.
I was definitely at that crossroads.
And I even had that, you know,
that thought process that it was like,
I'm gonna buy the apartment
and then I'm gonna feel like empowered by that.
And really like it so had nothing to do with buying anything
or owning anything.
And it was all like truly pushing
and pulling my own body weight.
It was the most basic thing I could figure out.
So even though that was two years prior,
there's this seed, little seedling that's growing,
that's going, yeah, don't get too invested
in what's going on here.
Yeah, and it was like,
and then it was like live below your means,
like save up money.
And if I hadn't done that,
there is no possible way I could have left.
There's no way.
'Cause I wouldn't have been able to afford to leave
and pay law school loans and, you know, life.
Yeah, that's the one thing I always say
to young people is like live lean.
Like, don't buy stuff.
Like, the best insurance policy on your freedom
and being able to make choices is to live lean.
Live as lean as possible when you're young.
Totally agreed.
Totally. And I'm so grateful that I,
I actually never, I rarely think about that.
And that was a real crossroads for me
that I didn't even recognize as one.
I was just like, ah, I'll figure this out later.
And then a few years later I'm like, oh my God,
I don't have a mortgage.
Like, this is major.
I can pick up and leave whenever I want.
I mean, freedom, portability, like, you know,
it's a very, those are very real concepts in my life.
All right, so type one diabetes.
Type one, man.
Like, that was so shocking when you just posted it
on Instagram one day.
And I was like, what?
I know.
Like, out of the blue. Like, first of all,
I didn't even know that that's the way it could work.
Like, I thought like type one was something,
of course type two we know there's a lot
of lifestyle components to that.
Type one is very different.
And that's something that, you know,
I thought was sort of more of like a genetic thing
that would've been diagnosed like very much earlier in life.
So yeah,
type one used to be called juvenile diabetes.
And it was just, I mean,
I just came back from a month long trip in India,
and I thought I was jet lagged or something,
and I felt really dehydrated.
And my mom's a physician and she was like,
this doesn't sound right. We need to get blood work.
So, it was like Tuesday, blood work,
Wednesday, endocrinologist, Thursday, I'm on insulin, like.
Out of the blue.
And they did an A1C test,
which basically goes back in your blood work
and like measures your glucose levels and all this stuff.
And for months, I mean,
I'd done three marathons with type one and I had no idea.
Like, I was just running at such a high level
that I was burning just enough sugar to not be hospitalized.
But essentially type one means
that your pancreas makes little or no insulin.
So, it's just an autoimmune disease.
And my pancreas just like, it's on strike forever.
Wow.
Like, it's just done.
And you were walking around
and running around with that for-
For months.
For like at least four months.
I mean, you could have just had a serious problem.
A big, actually most type ones are diagnosed
in the hospital 'cause there aren't any symptoms really.
And they have such high sugars that, I mean, your organs,
I mean, you have ketoacidosis
and tons of terrible stuff happens.
And the effects of running with
that high of sugar is pretty major for every single organ
in your body.
So, it's unbelievable.
And of course people are shocked.
I mean, it's like, I'm a really healthy person otherwise.
Very healthy.
And when my endo, I was like,
oh my God, is this pancreatic cancer, something crazy?
I mean, how could this happen to me?
And it was like, again, one of those pivotal moments
where the endocrinologist is like,
you have type one diabetes.
And I was like, no way.
And then I was like, what do I do about it?
How do I run ultras?
Like, literally that was like the first thing
that came out of my mouth.
And she was like pulling out like, you know,
this was like an emergency visit.
I didn't have an endocrinologist before.
So, she really didn't know me.
She just was looking at this blood work
and like diagnosing me on paper.
She's like, that's your first question?
Yeah, well she pulls out this like, you know,
USDA like food portion map or whatever.
I was like, listen, chick,
that's not the conversation we're having.
We're talking about how I can run a 100 mile race.
And my friend Steven England is an incredible athlete.
He's done like Leadville,
and he's training for a 200 mile race around Tahoe
in September.
And he's a type one diabetic.
He's had type one since he was 14.
He was one of the first people I called.
It was like my mom, Steven.
'Cause I just needed like that...
Thankfully I know him
'cause so much of the information out there,
even for athletes with type one,
there's a handful of Olympians,
but there's, it's not really,
it's not really out there in terms of like-
There's a professional cycling team
called Team Type One.
My friend Steven's on it.
Okay, cool.
Novo Nordisk is the team.
The sponsor, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, my friend Steven introduced those guys,
and he's part of the running component of that.
Oh cool.
So, there's a running team part of that.
Yeah, so it started as a cycling team,
and they've done like incredible stuff.
Yeah, there are like amazing cyclists on the team.
Amazing, amazing.
I mean, they're truly professional athletes.
And then there's a tri team
and then there's the running team.
And a lot of the runners are marathoners
and ultra marathoners.
So, Steven was like,
you're gonna have to figure out your own like treatment,
but yes, like this, this, and that are possible.
So, I felt better.
Right, so how does it, so like what does it mean?
Like, when you go out to train, like how do you-
So, I'm constantly battling low blood sugar.
That's the biggest thing for me.
You okay right now?
Yes, I'm okay.
I can, I mean, I can sense it thankfully.
I mean, because I have body awareness.
How do you know?
Do you get lightheaded or how does it come on?
It's like...
It's a combination of feeling voraciously hungry
and brain fog.
Like, for me, that's how I know.
It's like, I just feel fuzzy.
Like, your brain needs sugar to function, right.
If you go below a certain level, you'll be in a coma.
And most people their pancreas produces insulin
to sort of regulate that automatically.
As long as you're eating, you know,
in proportion to your body weight
and you're not, you know, being excess with your lifestyle,
like most people are pretty good.
And for me, I have an insulin pump
that gives me an eye drop of insulin every seven minutes.
Thankfully I have this pod
because the pod combined with the glucose monitoring device
that I have, both, I mean, technology is everything.
Like, I don't know how I would do it
if I had to carry needles around on like a four hour run
or something, like it would be insane.
So, basically I have a little personal monitoring device
that I adjust my insulin based on like what I do.
And it's like, so hold on.
So, it's like implanted in you?
Yeah, it's right here.
Oh, wow.
It's literally under my skin, but I move it.
So, I change this every three days,
and sometimes I wear it on my arm.
And I remember when, you know,
I was going through the training,
the lady's like, you know, you can put it on your arm,
you have to move it or else it creates scar tissue,
'cause it's really a needle that goes under your skin.
And I was like, oh, I would never wear it on my arm.
God, I like would never want to be public.
And then of course like 10 days later,
I'm like, what's up Instagram, here's my pod.
I'm loud and I'm proud.
But like I had to own it. Like, I just had to own it.
It's like that's my reality.
And they had never seen somebody
so aggressively pursue like all this technology.
I was like, give it all to me! I want all the data.
I want all the information.
I wanna be empowered.
And I mean, seriously, there wasn't even,
I didn't even waste an hour being like why?
I was like, you're just gonna have to deal with this
and you're strong enough, so go.
And that's what happened.
So, it sucks. I mean, I'm not gonna lie to you.
It's a 24/7 tight rope walk of making sure I'm
in between high and low.
And as an athlete, it's more battling lows
than anything else.
And, you know, I'll teach three recycling classes in a row
and like, I'll just have to like have something there,
like always, you know?
Right, you just have to plan ahead a little bit,
and just be on top and monitoring it.
But the only time you ever really felt
like you were almost getting in trouble was running
that marathon?
In San Diego.
I mean, I was like about to,
like without like something, some sugar in my system,
and it, there was no rhyme or reason for it.
It's like, I feel just like my training runs.
I feel just like a week, literally a week prior,
same distance, same fuel, same goose,
same whatever, same game plan.
Body just reacted differently.
And it's just like, you know, that's the unpredictability.
80% of the time,
this is how Steven explained it to me and it's totally true.
once you have an understanding of your diabetes,
like you got it under control,
but then there's that 20% that like your body
just goes crazy.
Like, you just don't know.
So you just have to always be ready
in the event of that unpredictable moment.
Yeah, I mean, it's like, snacks.
Like, I mean, I literally like at any given time of day,
I probably have like a honey stinger in my sports bra.
(Robin laughs)
Like, I probably have like food tucked away somewhere,
even though I'm wearing
like all of two articles of clothing.
(everyone laughs)
Cool.
So, I want to talk about kind of,
when you gave your talk at Catalyst,
it was really the theme of it was like tell your own story.
Yeah.
Like, be your own story.
And how does that...
You know, how do you kind of communicate that
to the people that you work with
to help raise their bar of their experience?
'Cause I mean, a big part of,
I think a big part of living a passionate life,
and you exude this, is giving back, right?
Like, a part of what gets you out of the bed
in the morning is that you know
that you're helping other people
and that you're having a positive impact on others,
and that's a huge motivating factor
and it's a big part of, you know,
basically your own personal fulfillment
like happiness equation, right?
So, what is the mechanism by which you are able,
like there's, let me back up.
There's nothing more powerful than a good story well told.
So, and the ability to effectively communicate a good story,
whether it's your story or somebody else's story,
is one of the most empowering and inspirational things
that you can do.
And you're very good at it.
And your lifestyle is like an extrapolation of that, right?
So, how does that like kind of,
how do you infuse that into the people
that you're interacting with?
That's a pretty vague question.
No, I mean, kind of.
(Robin laughs)
Do you know what I'm getting at though?
Well, I think you're asking-
Like, I really just wanna talk about story.
Yeah, well, how do you, how do you own it?
I mean, I think it really goes back to people talk
when they're figuring out like a startup or whatever.
It's like, what are your brand values?
Like, we have so much conversation
around like how marketing should look or feel or sound.
And what I really like to encourage people
to think about is,
you are the CEO of your body, like head to toe.
What are you putting out into the world
in what you do and what you say and how you feel?
How you feel is one of the best things
that you can do is take care of yourself.
That's a service to others.
That's not selfish.
That's taking care of your own home,
your own, like, you know, body
and being of service to the world
in whatever capacity you can be.
And I think the owning, the empowerment of it,
I discovered it through physical activity.
Like, I really think that some type of fitness is a way
to tap into unlocking your why.
And I think when you identify your why,
then all these other things fall into place.
You have a little bit more clarity,
like the cleaning, you know, the cleaning of the cob web
so to speak that you sort of mentioned.
Like, making sure your internal compass is, is dialed in.
I do think that, I really do think that sweat is cathartic
in a really major way.
And not to say that, you know, somebody's gonna go for a run
and decide like, oh, I wanna be an ultra runner.
Oh, I wanna, you know, be X, Y, Z in related to sports
or wellness, not to say that at all.
But I do think that there's some clarity that comes with it.
And I think from there, from sort of that base,
then you start to realize like the literal
and visual conversations that you're having with the world.
And I think,
especially because of the social media fragmentation,
we kind of are looking at things
in like this really jarring like Instagram post,
Facebook post, tweet, FOMO, YOLO, like all these,
like, I mean, really that's just like,
that's a modern day just existential
like question of nowness.
And I think when we're thinking
of what our legacy is gonna be
and all these really lofty questions,
at the end of the day, it's just like are you living
and writing stories that are gonna be really juicy
when you're 90?
Are you doing something that matters in your gut?
Not because it's, you know, some lofty linear story,
literally that, you know, that could be fictionalized,
but because you're making connections with people
and building community and like, you know, eating real food
and just like all these little things,
like it's all about the little things.
And what I think my point is when you're saying,
write your story, when I'm saying,
write your story and own the pen,
it's more like, are the little decisions and little thoughts
that you're having every day adding up
to this larger picture that you see for yourself?
And I think people should take excitement in that.
Like, there is just so much power in that ability
to literally stop the thing that you're doing
that's not nourishing you or the world
and cut that shit out, do something epic.
Like, it's not that easy, but it is that easy.
Yeah, I mean, I think the trick is
for the person who feels trapped and they're like,
well, that's great, but like, I can't do that, you know,
it's about that first step.
Like, what's that first letter that you're writing
when you're writing your story, just write one letter.
Right, start with something.
You have to start with something.
Surround yourself with inspiration.
And you don't need to know what your legacy is.
You know what I mean? You just have to follow a thread.
Like, I'm feeling pulled in the direction
of trying to learn how to play the drums or whatever it is.
It could be the stupidest thing in the world, you know?
And I think there's a lot of embarrassment
around that kind of stuff.
It's like, these are juvenile aspirations
that we've been told, you know, we should sort of push aside
and get into the business of being responsible adults.
Well, I think the process of reinvention,
first of all, I think it should happen always.
But secondly, I think especially as adults,
we feel like, well, I already wrote my story.
I'm already this, and I'm already that,
and I'm already a dad, and I'm already-
This is who I am.
I'm already like, this is me.
But like you're evolving every day.
Like, literally on a cellular level, you're always evolving.
So, like take your body's cue and just bring it up here,
and, you know, allow yourself the freedom to not know.
And when we go back to thinking why we pursue certain things
as kids, like, it's just because you're like that seems fun.
Yeah, there's nothing else going on
other than that, right?
You know?
Don't follow somebody else's script.
Like, go take the cooking class, go take the drum lessons.
Like, somebody was in my class the other day,
and she was like, God, I always really wanted
to take a ballet class.
I was like, do it.
Like, who cares?
Yeah, you're probably never gonna be in the New York Ballet
at like X years old, but why not?
Just fricking do it.
You don't know what that's gonna open up.
Like, maybe you're meant to be the PR person for that.
You know, it's like, you just don't know
how the dominoes are gonna fall.
And you shouldn't necessarily
even try to understand that.
You know what I mean?
And I think that what happens is
whether it's your story of going from corporate lawyer
to the things that you're doing now,
or, you know, Dan Harris going from having a panic attack
on national television in front of five million people
to being like this advocate for meditation.
The sort of media narrative is to compress that and to-
It's like a 30 second, yeah.
This just happened overnight.
Like, you were a corporate lawyer,
and you snapped your fingers
and now you're like doing all this amazing stuff.
Or, you know, I lost 50 pounds in two minutes
and ran Ultraman like a week later, you know?
And it's like, when you look at the timeline,
like I was talking about this with Dan,
he had his panic attack in 2004,
and he didn't do his first five minute meditation
until 2009.
That's five years later.
So, it's like the neatly packaged narrative that the media,
you know, is shoving down your throat isn't actually real.
You know, this is like hard work.
And it's like, you know, throwing pebbles in the pond
and putting your toe in the water and then slipping
and doing a million things that are embarrassing
and messing up and failing and not knowing what you're doing
and questioning yourself and all of these things.
But all of those things are not failures.
They're successes
because they're just steps along this journey, you know?
And so, I think the important thing is to embark
on the journey,
to have the courage to embrace the not knowing.
And it doesn't have to be about goal setting
or achieving some objective.
It's about just embracing something different and new,
something that might be intimidating
but you're inexplicably drawn to,
and just not trying to understand the why behind it.
Yeah, and I think almost all of my lessons
in the past few years have been in retrospect.
Like, it's not like
in the moment I'm necessarily understanding the poignancy
of something in that time.
I think it's the reflection that's important.
You look back on it and it seems to create this,
you can create, you can write your story retrospectively
by looking backwards
and going, oh, this makes perfect sense, of course.
You know what I mean?
Like, you know, Dan Harris got assigned
to cover spirituality and religion, you know,
he didn't want to, you know, and that set him on a,
he didn't know why he was doing that then.
You look back now and it's like, oh, like,
that's something that a novelist would've fabricated
for a book, you know, like that doesn't just happen.
And that's happened to me many times,
these weird things that have happened.
I'm sure you've experienced that.
Yeah, absolutely.
And then you can write the narrative
like backwards like that.
But when it's happening, it doesn't make sense.
You don't understand it.
And I think it's about being okay with that.
Yeah, you do.
And I think that being okay with that discomfort,
like a lot of life is uncomfortable.
It's not always gonna be like...
I do believe in celebrating little victories, 100%,
but most of the time, if you have any type of momentum,
you're gonna have discomfort,
a lot of discomfort along the way.
Well, discomfort is the crucible for growth
and change anyway.
Like, you should welcome the discomfort.
If you're uncomfortable, then something's happening.
Yeah.
You know?
I mean, I feel that all the time.
And I think people, like you mentioned about Dan Harris,
or even people's like success stories, you know,
you look at people, whatever Warren Buffet,
like these icons in Western society.
And when you, you know, when you take down,
you break down those stories, you know,
whether in their books or whatever,
you're like, damn, that was a lot of hustle.
Like, that was a lot of little stepping zones
and a lot of seeds planted.
Like, I say like plant a whole field of seeds.
You don't know what's gonna sprout.
Like, those connections might not even happen
until decades later.
And it is in retrospect that sort of the synchronicity
of things kind of pop up, and you're like, whoa,
like that was absolutely supposed to happen for me.
Right.
And it's about not judging, not making judgment calls
on the good or the bad of whatever is happening.
Like, right before, right when you walked in,
we were talking before we started recording,
and you were supposed to go to LA and do this TV show.
Yep, in three days.
On social media, you were getting all ready to go,
it's an exciting thing.
And then at the last minute, the plug got pulled.
So, what happened?
So I was supposed to,
I'm still so frustrated about this!
Literally the executive producer called me like an hour ago,
I was supposed to be on this show with NBC
and Esquire Network where it was called "Enter the Wild,"
and we were gonna literally live in the wild for a month
with this survival tracker, professional guy, Tom Brown.
And apparently he pulled out from the show.
And now it's-
Three days before.
Three days.
I mean, this was like,
if anyone can imagine taking a month away from your life,
literally off the grid, no business calls, no family calls,
nothing.
Yeah, you gotta get ready for that.
I mean, that is like-
A lot of prep.
That is everything.
And I work with, because I have such like a,
my work is like with a lot of different brands
and a lot of different studios.
It's not like I tell one boss and I take a leave, you know?
I had to like to contact like 20 people to get their okay
or just to give them notice.
So, yes, to say that that was like,
I mean, that was a blow, man.
And just that call.
And I was so excited about it.
I was excited about like doing this amazing thing.
I was like, this is my next adventure.
Like, this is, you know, you kind of,
I'm in that place where I'm like, what's next?
Like, I want something else.
I want something else.
And the driven part of me is like, yeah,
that's your challenge.
You're gonna be some warrior chick in the woods.
(Robin laughs)
And yeah, it looks like very likely is not gonna happen now.
And...
But it's-
And that's creating space, but I know,
well enough to know that is creating space
for whatever it is I am supposed to be doing.
Yeah, I mean,
the next thing I came outta your mouth was like,
well, there obviously is something better,
or I wasn't supposed to do that.
It sort of, you were talking about planting a ton of seeds.
Well, that was a seed that germinated
and was starting to grow and was about to sprout
and the lawn mower just ran it over.
So, it's like, all right, well,
what other seeds look like they're popping up over here
and let's just go over there.
Yeah, and like, you know,
my sister's going to Thailand next week from India,
and I'm like, maybe I should be going to Thailand.
You know, I mean, it's just like that's how my mind works.
And it's only through falling flat on my face so many times
and wallowing does nothing.
It does nothing.
Not to say you shouldn't let like those,
just the disappointment.
You should feel it, you know, you should feel how you feel.
But just gotta move on to the next thing.
How was India?
God, I can't wait to go back.
My sister's living there for another year,
so I will have an opportunity to be there again.
Where were you in India?
I was in...
My sister was living in Delhi at the time.
So, I was in Delhi and then we went to Agra
where the Taj Mahal was, which is,
have you been to Taj Mahal?
Never been.
It is like just as impressive
as you'd think it'd be.
Like, gasp worthy.
That will never become a cliche.
Like, Taj Mahal is as epic as it should be.
So, we went to Taj Mahal.
Then we went to Rishikesh, which is an amazing area,
which is kind of like,
it's where The Beatles learned to meditate.
It's kind of like dubbed as the birthplace-
Lots of ashrams.
Yeah, lots of ashrams.
Birthplace of meditation, all that.
And that was amazing.
Like, so many people searching,
like I have never been in a place
where you just felt like people were seeking and craving
and wanting like answers, like with a capital A, Answers.
And that was really like weird and neat.
I kind of thought it'd be like this zen yoga place
and there's tons of yoga, but not like Western yoga.
Very hatha yoga.
Very, very different types of yoga than I'm used to,
which is a vinyasa practice.
But what was so interesting to me was not the yoga at all.
It was more like the interactions with like travelers
and these like just nomadic kind of folks
who find themselves at like a satsang in this random,
you know, it was like this Brazilian,
picture of this like Brazilian guru
and 100 random people just like chanting.
And I'm like, and they're all very visually different,
all colors, all ages.
And I'm just like, we all are here.
Like, it was just, it was a weird,
you know, it's rare that I have these like moments
to just give me absolute pause.
And I'm like, this is like, we're all here
in this time space continuum.
I don't know.
It was like this really like weird snapshot
that I recognized as a snapshot, which is also rare.
So, but so India was amazing.
Rishikesh was just such a trip and beautiful
and right at the foot of the Himalayas.
Goa, we also spent some time in Goa, Southern beaches.
That was amazing.
We were in, oh my God, what was the name of the beach?
The most Southern beach.
Totally forgetting now.
Goa is pretty south too, isn't it?
No, yeah, so Goa is the most Southern state,
but then the most Southern beach in Goa is where we were,
and I can not believe I'm forgetting the name,
maybe that's good thing
'cause I don't want it to get overcrowded
'cause it's already getting too touristy.
But it was such a gift to be able to hang out with my mom
and my sister. Like, I don't remember the last time we spent
more than three days together.
So, I think, you know, I have a tattoo on my arm.
These are swallows and it's three birds,
and the middle one is my mom, the bottom one is my sister,
the top one is me.
And it just kind of honors all our journeys.
And my mom is a real example of reinvention.
She's a Cuban refugee
and taught herself English watching "Sesame Street" and PBS
at 16.
And then, you know, eight years later was,
you know, in medical school.
So, she's a really inspiring story for me.
And then my sister, even though she's my little sister,
is way wiser than I probably will ever be.
And is now living in India and working for an NGO
and just literally changing the world.
So, I have, I'm sort of bookended by these amazing women
who inspire me in very, very unique ways,
and it wasn't lost on me that we were
kind of like all three of us on this beach in India
and I managed to take a month off,
and it was just like very, I was like, okay, sunshine,
this is it, like literally in a bottle.
So, it was great.
That's really cool.
What do you think about this sort of dearth
of female role models?
You know, we're in the world of the Kardashians
and, you know, "The Bachelorette,"
and all this sort of thing.
And there just really aren't, you know,
we're in a crisis when it comes to that.
It's a huge crisis.
I mean, I mean, thank-
And it's not that there aren't amazing women doing
incredibly inspiring things all over the place,
but it's a misdirect when it comes to media.
The most readily available images.
Absolutely.
I mean, I'm lucky and your kids are lucky
because they're surrounded by, you know, their mom,
but I was, I think it...
Unfortunately it's starting from the closest images
that you have to you for a lot of girls.
And I don't know how to change it.
I mean, I would like to think like that is really one
of the things I wanna do with Undo.
You know, we sort of feature these vignettes
and empowering stories of real people doing awesome stuff.
And we wanna encourage people to tell their stories
and be visible and vocal about the stuff that they're doing
'cause then, you know,
that sort of raises the consciousness a little bit
and the dialogue.
But, you know, in terms of like crazy celebrity culture
and the rabbit hole of like Us Weekly,
which I will definitely buy on a plane
and, you know, whatever.
I've done it, I admit it.
But, you know, I'm also old enough to know.
You know, it's like, would I give that to like a little kid
and show that as an example of what to be in the world?
Absolutely not.
So, I don't know, man.
But I think that,
I think that there is a mass yearning for that.
It's not, it's not an isolated thing.
So, it seems like it could be something
that you could weave into the brand consultancy work
that you do.
Like, to be able to, you know, sort of, you know,
raise the pedestal of maybe some women
that you haven't heard of
and put them, you know, in an ad for a brand
in a way that's aspirational for young girls, you know?
There has to be opportunities for that
to work within the system.
And there are really good organizations
that I've worked with.
Like, I Am That Girl is kind of,
the messaging behind it is really cool.
It's kind of like, I am that girl who's,
it's basically getting accomplished people to be like,
yeah, I am that girl who was made fun of for running,
which I literally was.
I was made fun of by the way for how I ran
when I was in sixth grade.
You know, little things like that
to sort of like spark dialogue and inspire folks.
But I think from like,
from an aesthetic perspective,
from like a stylized perspective,
it's really important to sort of bring people
from like the fray and bring them in.
And I feel like
that's sort of what the running crew community did
for runners.
And I think that it's something
that the wellness movement can now do for women.
Like, I think that it is absolutely a beacon of,
I think the wellness movement is a beacon of light for women
and in a really healthy way,
not in a way that's focused on body image,
but in a way that's focused on empowerment
in a very different,
it's a different type of feminism I think honestly.
Interesting.
We gotta wrap it up here in a couple minutes,
but I did want to ask you about your experience going up
to Vermont and working with the Love Your Brain guys
with Kevin.
I love those guys!
So when we were in Vegas,
we had that great honor of meeting the Pearce brothers.
And Kevin Pearce, for those who don't know,
was a incredible snowboarder
who was well on his way to the Olympics
and potentially beating Shaun White.
And he had a massive head injury shortly before,
two Olympics ago, right?
And it's been a long road back for him with his health,
and he's doing great now.
There was an amazing documentary made
about his life called "The Crash Reel," which was on HBO.
I don't know if it's still airing.
But if you have a chance to see this documentary,
it's extraordinary.
And Robin and I both had the great opportunity
to meet these guys at this event.
And it was really touching.
You know, they're special guys for sure.
Very special guys.
And you, and they put together,
so they have a nonprofit called Love Your Brain.
And they were putting together a group of people to do the,
this, the Burlington marathon,
and you wanted to coach them and get them ready.
So, I wanna hear about that.
It was so fun.
I mean, gosh, that was,
so Adam and Kevin reached out to me to coach the team
and Love Your Brain had a lot of different participants
on the team.
So, the Burlington marathon allows people to participate
in the marathon as a relay,
as a half, or as a full distance.
So, people kind of pick the distances they were capable
of running,
and Will Halby has, his family has a farm
in Vermont called, oh my God...
I can't believe I'm forgetting the name of this either.
My brain. So, they have a farm in Vermont.
And I'm so sorry I forget the name.
But they host us and they have this like amazing community
that they basically allow nonprofits to come
and, you know, host their events there.
The pictures looked incredible.
It's stunning.
And for me, like speaking of nature from Newark, that was-
Yeah, being an urban girl.
That, I mean, I was like,
oh, I really needed this air.
I needed this greenery.
And, you know, like truly on a cellular level, I needed it.
So, I basically helped coach the 70 person team.
And, you know, some people were running 5Ks,
some people were running 10Ks,
a few people were running the full,
bunch of people running the half.
And we spent five days out there,
and it was so much more than a marathon.
Like, I got there on a Thursday,
and we had like a storytelling circle
where you have traumatic brain injury victims talking about,
you know, one girl was thrown off a horse
and like, she's, you know, basically,
you know, wheelchair bound.
She walked a mile of, you know,
assisted, she walked a mile of the marathon.
So, little things like that are not so little when you make,
when people tell their stories
and like your jaw's on the floor.
Like, I can't believe I'm surrounded by so much goodness.
And so, it was really about raising awareness
for traumatic brain injury and prevention.
And I think what Love Your Brain is doing
now entering sort of this like team based sports world
is really cool because you're allowing the actual survivors
to do something that's really empowering.
Then you're spreading the message on prevention.
And then you're creating this team bond around running,
which is like freaking awesome.
So, it was a five day camp and basically both the survivors
and some educators and family members all came together.
You know, we did yoga, we had meditations, we cooked food,
like an all like sort of brain rich foods.
It was just like a 24 hour...
Awesome fest.
Awesome fest for five days.
Yeah, so a five day awesome fest.
And like love fest.
Like, by the end, we're all just like,
literally we're having a dance in the barn
and, oh, Zeno Mountain Farm.
That's the name of the farm.
I knew it was in there.
So, then we're just having a, you know,
we're literally like dancing with our shoes off
and they had a DJ,
and it was just like, when do you get to do that?
It was so special.
So, we're gonna do that again.
We're definitely gonna do that again.
Cool, cool, cool.
And you have to join us!
Yeah, I would love to. Actually, Adam emailed me.
He was like, hey, can you help
with some of the nutrition stuff?
And I think I was in the Middle East, something,
I was traveling and just wires got crossed.
I didn't get back to him right away,
but I would love, you know,
I wanna support what those guys are doing.
They're doing amazing work, and there's a need for it.
Such a need.
And such a misunderstanding.
I mean, to be honest, it was 'cause of Love Your Brain
that I started wearing a bike helmet.
And I just had a crash like last week.
I mean, I'm totally fine.
But I ended up getting dinged in my back wheel, like,
you know, I just went, went over,
and there's no, I mean, a brain is a pretty cute accessory,
so I need, I need that.
So, I'm really-
You can't be riding your bike in New York City
without a helmet.
Dude, for five years I did.
That's crazy.
I know.
It's stupid.
It's absolutely stupid.
But, you know, I know a lot of people do it,
and it was truly 'cause of that five day weekend
where I was like, God, this is important.
And not only is it important,
it's a total slap in the face to these people
who I like admire and respect so much
and like I can't, yeah, I gotta be on board with that.
When you see that up close like that.
Yeah, and there's stories where, I mean,
it's like one woman fell off a ladder
and like had to get like part of her vocal chords removed.
I mean, and like now has like,
it's just, it's a problem that a lot of times isn't visible
and TBI survivors, like they're battling it kind of silently
a lot of the time.
And I think
what Love Your Brain is doing is raising awareness.
And then Kevin is just such an inspiring guy
and such a genuine dude.
And their family is so special.
So, they're really good, important,
necessary leaders of that.
Yeah, it's an amazing family, you know.
That documentary really is about,
it's really a family story as much as anything else.
And, you know, Kevin's just a love.
I mean-
He is, he is!
He is love, he is love.
And I got to meet his parents,
and I was just like, you guys, I feel like, you're like,
I love you!
And they probably get it all the time
'cause they're like total complete strangers see
this documentary,
and they're just like, you're so special.
Yeah, and they all are.
And they, it's weird.
It's not weird.
It's fantastic that they happened to be so sort of in tune
with relationships that they picked,
they cultivated such a special group of people
for this camp.
Like, it wasn't just like you applied and went.
It was like people who really cared about sharing.
And it wasn't necessarily about sharing TBI stories.
It was just like about story and about connection
and about feeling inspired no matter
where you are coming from and then leaving
and taking that into your community
and like doing something.
And that spark, I mean, those are the seeds.
Those are the sparks that create movements.
So, I'm really happy to know those guys.
Yeah, cool.
Well, I think that's a great place to stop.
Yeah, that was awesome.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you so much.
So cool.
I love having you.
You were fantastic.
This flew by.
I know it goes fast, right?
So fast.
Right?
So, everybody out there, start writing your own story.
Yeah, man.
Own the pen.
That's right.
And if you're digging,
if you're crushing, I should say on Robin,
the best way to seek her out
and stalk her would be on Instagram.
It's @RobinNYC, right?
That's right.
And on Twitter is the same?
Yep.
And RobinArzon.com.
RobinArzon.com.
All right, cool.
Well, I love you.
It was fantastic.
I love you too, thanks, Rich.
Thanks so much, and we'll do it again,
next time I come to New York. All right, peace.
Peace.
(Robin laughs)
(chill music)